bonjour à tous bienvenue par le brave de
45 minutes pour faire le tour de l'actu
politique parlementaire bonjour katia
bonjour michael et cette semaine dans
l'actualité en début de semaine les yeux
étaient rivés vers l'onu la question
syrienne est au centre de tous les
débats à la veille la france avait lancé
ses premières frappées en fin de semaine
l'a dit mi-août il a été reçu à l'elysée
actualité aussi avec michel sapin qui a
dévoilé le budget 2016 c'est le dernier
du quinquennat de françois hollande le
gouvernement a prévu de faire 16
milliards d'euros d'économies que
réduire le déficit promesses aussi de
baisses d'impôts au parlement nouveau
règlement au sénat entrée en vigueur
cette semaine les absents seront frappés
au portefeuille plus de transparence
dans les finances d'un travail
parlementaire mieux encadré explications
dans quelques minutes et barbara pompili
est notre invité cette semaine bonjour
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation vous êtes député de la somme
vous avez quitté il ya quelques jours
europe ecologie les verts et vous êtes
toujours co présidente du groupe
écologiste à l'assemblée on va en parler
mais je vous propose d'abord un petit
portrait de vous vu par vos collègues
parma pompiers quelqu'un qui prend bien
la lumière est ce qu elle l'apprend trop
c'est une vraie question dynamique récit
assez ce qu'elle veut elle ira loin et
sympathique est déterminé femmes
engagées dans les politiques qui
animerait conduction solide
lorsqu'elle a tiré un trait
sur le fonctionnement de cette famille
politique dont on aurait bien qu'elle
est déchiré un peu plus chaque jour
je regrette qu'elle quitte europe
ecologie les verts parce que je pense
qu'on a un moment où il faut pas laisser
la gauche émiettée
je pense que ça n'est bon pour personne
et vous mieux souvent rompent avec un
groupe si on n'est plus d'accord avec
les idées de ce groupe et continuer à
avancer dans son travail et dans son
action c'est ce qu'elle a fait elle
donne une belle image de des questions
environnementales qu'elle porte très
honnête et d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'on
voit dans sa décision d'aujourd'hui
c'est un choix de clarté et de cohérence
et d'honnêteté
c'est quelqu'un de claire de cohérent et
d'honnête alors voilà barbara bon
feeling je sais que vous avez déjà dit
beaucoup de choses sur cette décision
vous acquittez europe ecologie les verts
est publiée sur la page facebook une
tribune qu' au dans laquelle on sent que
vous en avez vraiment gros sur le coeur
alors c'est quoi c'est un ras-le-bol de
la colère forte
non c c'est l'idée de passer à autre
chose maintenant j'ai fait le constat
que au sein d'europe écologie les verts
aujourd'hui la famille écologiste toute
la famille écologiste ne peut plus vivre
donc au bout d'un moment il faut savoir
passer à autre chose
donc c'est un constat d'échec mais en
même temps c'est une volonté vraiment
d'aller de l'avant et surtout avec les
élections régionales dans ma région en
nord-pas-de-calais picardie pour essayer
justement contrairement à ce que
certains disent de rassembler toute la
gauche parce que là on a un enjeu très
grave on à l'extrême droite qui peut
prendre une région une région 6 millions
d'habitants qui n'a certainement pas
besoin de ça
et face à ça aujourd'hui c'est la
division c'est le les invectives et on
ne peut pas continuer comme ça il ya un
côté négatif même quand on démissionne
oui il y a un côté négatif mais c'est
pour ça que j'essaye vraiment de passer
à autre chose je ne me suis pas plus
s'exprimer que ça sur le sujet j'ai fait
deux écrit un dans le monde et une
tribune plus longue pour expliquer
pourquoi je partais maintenant je veux
être dans le positif je veux être dans
la construction et la construction c'est
justement de relier tous ces citoyens
dans le nord-pas-de-calais qui ont
besoin
nous pour les aider à porter leurs voix
ont fait un constat d'échec des partis
politiques aujourd'hui ça ne marche plus
les parties alors ça c'est une vraie
question
les partis politiques aujourd'hui on
voit que leur base militante et de plus
en plus étroite
il y a des gens qui ne sont plus
représentés les partis politiques les
chômeurs les ouvriers les jeunes on ne
les voit plus dans les partis parce que
il ne considère plus que c'est un
débouché
donc on aura toujours besoin de partis
politiques mais il faut ce vraiment
repenser leur fonctionnement repenser
leurs liens avec les citoyens et ça
c'est une aventure que j'ai envie de
mener est ce qu'on aura toujours besoin
d'un groupe écologiste à l'assemblée
parce que j'ai toujours jusqu'à preuve
de contraire coprésidente du groupe à
l'assemblée alors qu'est-ce qui devient
second alors oui là pour le coup je
regrette qu europe ecologie les verts et
perdu l'esprit qui était le sien au
départ qui était de réunir tous les
écologistes
eh bien nous essayons mais ce n'est pas
facile d'avoir cet esprit-là au groupe à
l'assemblée et au groupe au sénat a
d'ailleurs c'est que tous les
écologistes puisse porter leur parole
qui peut être une parole diverses et
elle l'est à travers un groupe politique
donc moi j'y tiens beaucoup fait rien de
décidé pour l'instant
ah ben on est encore dans les
négociations c'est un équilibre des
immeubles bas peut-être est un équilibre
délicat on a des gens qui sont à élever
des gens qui n'y sont plus des gens qui
sont dans un autre parti des gens qui ne
sont pas vrais lorsque délicat quand
même ans et c'est délicat
il y adeux l'affectif aussi donc il faut
réussir à faire monter justement ce
mélange délicat pour arriver à faire en
sorte que la parole écologiste dans sa
diversité existe toujours dans nos
institutions à loeb de la cap 21
avec tous les enjeux sur la pollution
sur la santé publique on a besoin de
nous nous serons là
est-ce que vous avez conscience par bach
accompli que les parties que vous
méritez europe ecologie les verts est au
bord de l'implosion
et là vous venez peut-être d'allumer
encore images supplémentaires
écoutez moi je ne m'en réjouis pas mais
ce n'est plus mon affaire maintenant je
veux reconstruire l'écologie politique
l'écologie politique dans toute sa
richesse si ça ne se fait plus au sein
d'europe écologie ça se fera ailleurs et
ce n'est pas grave dans un sens les
parties ce n'est pas quelque chose
d'immuable c'est des choses qui
pouvaient ce qui vous dit vous quitter
le navire pour rejoindre le parti
majoritaire aujourd'hui le parti
socialiste avec
je trouve de françois hollande non non
non non non je suis écologiste je reste
écologiste je respecte les autres
familles politiques
mais ma famille c'est la famille de
l'écologie est elle doit exister en tant
que tel
après qu'elle passe des alliances des
accords politiques parlent avec d'autres
marty mais c'est logique ça c'est la vie
de la démocratie donc évidemment je
reste d'écologistes et je porterai cette
parole très fort encore le réseau actuel
on y revient dans quelques minutes et
d'abord la semaine qui commence avec les
premières frappes françaises dans le
ciel syrien les rafale français sont
donc entrés en action dans le ciel
syrien détruisant un camp d'entraînement
de djihadistes paris a invoqué la
légitime défense pour justifier son
intervention et quelques réactions et
inquiétude à l'assemblée écoutez il faut
que la france et que l'europe pèse dans
les négociations internationales
aujourd'hui on peut pas se contenter
d'attendre le résultat d'une discussion
entre monsieur obama et monsieur poutine
et donc nous demandons à l'europe et
notamment à françois hollande de prendre
des initiatives et de ne pas regarder
les trains passer
quel est celui qui a dit dès le départ
il faut régler le cas de bachar assad el
assad
quel est celui qui a dit moi je suis
prêt à participer à une coalition
c'est la france il a fallu qu'obama
connaissent des difficultés avec le
congrès et que les anglais disent non
pour que l'on ait encore bachar el-assad
aujourd'hui comme premier des assassins
de son peuple on peut pas régler le
problème en syrie / ne s'appuie pas sur
l'aide que la russie propose et sur
bachar el-assad qui au moins lui
à la différence de l'état islamique à
une structure avec laquelle on peut
dialoguer qui est capable d'entendre des
exigences on peut quand même le souhaite
lui à des exigences
alors justement la russie et damas
partenaires incontournables ou
encombrants au contraire ils sont des
partenaires
vraiment il faut qu'ils rentrent dans le
concert des nations pour essayer de
trouver une solution
ce qui se passe en syrie donc je ne suis
pas du tout pour rejeter au contraire
poutine pour rejeter de l'iran ils ont
un rôle à jouer
maintenant on voit bien que ils sont
très ambigu sur ce qu'ils font en syrie
aujourd'hui on est en train de se dire
que les frappes qui sont menées
notamment par par poutine sont des
frappes qui ont plus vocation à
renforcer le régime de bachar al assad
que de régler le problème
aujourd'hui on a une guerre dans ce pays
qui est une guerre qui oppose aussi
différentes différents types de
population on a les kurdes en année
sunnite on a les chiites
il ne faut surtout pas que la coalition
laisse faire disons une guerre des uns
contre les autres maintenant il faut et
nous on l'a dit depuis très longtemps
au-delà des questions des frappes il
faut une conférence régionale sur la
syrie pour trouver des solutions pour
faire en sorte qu'on reconstruise
politiquement ce pays est-ce que c'est
avec bachar al assad fait la question
parce que jean luc mélenchon par exemple
il propose un dialogue approfondi avec
bachar al assad et vous non bachar al
assad
il est quand même responsable de plus de
80% des morts de cette guerre donc les
encore donc bachar al assad pour moi ne
peut pas participer à la solution par
contre par contre il va bien falloir
reconstruire avec les syriens et donc on
ne va pas écarter toulon il va falloir
discuter avec tout le monde y compris
des jours où les cartes et vous écarter
de la chaire de la fable mais bachar al
assad ne peut pas être une solution
il a tiré sur son peuple il a gazé son
goût pour vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec
ce que propose jean luc mélenchon non
non c'est pas la première dans ce palais
prépare à passer au mardi le ps prépare
sur le fardeau
alors reconnaît la question qui sera
posée au peuple de gauche entre le 16 et
le 18 octobre face à la droite et
l'extrême droite souhaitez-vous l'unité
de la gauche et des écologistes aux
élections régionales tu imagines que ça
ça vous vous intéressez barbara pompili
on va écouter quelques réactions à
gauche notamment au parti socialiste
revient pour débattre je pense que c'est
un élément majeur quand on voit qu'il y
à gauche
aujourd'hui un certain nombre de nos
partenaires qui veulent empêcher de
battre la droite au second tour et qui
pour cela sont prêts dans des
collectivités à se maintenir il faut que
les électeurs 10,1 leurs envies de
rassemblement 2 le fait que battre la
droite se doit être sur le deuxième tour
d'une élection
la constante de tous les partis de
gauche je ne vois ni stratégie ni
idéologie dans ce référendum je crois
que c'est une tentative peut-être aussi
d'expliquer par avance les difficultés
que nous pouvons avoir
au moment des élections régionales donc
le problème aujourd'hui c'est pas de
chercher des par avance des boucs
émissaires c'est plutôt de chercher ce
que peut être une politique porté par
toute la gauche avoir pompé les roues
touchent là vraiment au coeur du divorce
entre les verts et le parti socialiste
c'est une des raisons qui l'a fait pour
laquelle vous avez démissionné bon
question d'ego king vous irez voter aux
régionales
donc on se réfère demain c'est une vraie
question pour le référendum
franchement je ne sais pas encore je ne
sais pas si la la la question qui est
posée est la bonne en fait parce que
d'abord faire appel aux gens de faire
appel aux citoyens ce plutôt une bonne
idée
simplement quand c'est un parti
politique qui fait il pose cette
question forcément l'arrière pensée
c'est il faut que tout le monde se
réunissent autour de nous et se réunir
autour de nous vu justement le passif
cas le parti socialiste aujourd'hui vu
les questions légitimes que se posent
les citoyens sur l'action du
gouvernement par rapport à ce qui était
prévu en 2012 dire écoutez là la seule
solution c'est que vous réunissiez
autour de nous je ne suis pas sûr soit
une bonne chose par contre par contre
aujourd'hui il est évident que une
gauche désunie quand il ya un risque
front national et c'est pour ça que là
moi je parle surtout des lieux où il ya
des risques
grave du front national la région de
picardie c'est le cas de ma région nord
pas de calais picardie c'est le cas de
paca regardons aussi alsace lorraine
champagne ardenne ou à mon avis on
sous-estimé le risque dans ces régions
là on ne peut pas se permettre de croire
qu'on va créer une dynamique dans les 4
jours de campagne de l'emploi de demain
ça n'existe justement si le 13 décembre
le fn passe dans la région vous
remercierez qui écoute et je ne serais
pas là pour pour dire c'est la faute des
uns et les autres si jamais ça arrive
malheureusement il va falloir rentrer
dans une nouvelle phase et une nouvelle
phase 2 de résistance mais moi je n'ai
pas du tout envie aujourd'hui de rester
les bras croisés en attendant pourquoi
alors la résistance
elle passe par le fait qu'aujourd'hui
nous avons des citoyens qui sont en
train de se lever dans le nord pas de
calais c'est encore faible c'est encore
fragile mais ils sont en train de se
lever il dise voilà nous sommes des
citoyens de gauche
nous voulons absolument que les parties
que les appareils politiques arrêtent
d'être dans leurs petites bisbilles de
se regarder le nombril
maintenant nous devons créer une
dynamique crée une forme de front
populaire parce qu'on en est là un front
populaire et sociale et écologique qui
permettent de redonner une envie aux
mesures d'aidés liste parue nouveau
parador alors que musulman qu'on n'a pas
envie de faire la révolution en tout cas
ce qui est ce qu'ils se sont lancés ce
qu'ils veulent c'est simplement faire un
appel à la raison et dire maintenant
vous vous réunissez on recrée ensemble
une dynamique on montre que la gauche
est assez intelligente pour passer au
dessus de ces problèmes quand il ya un
enjeu supérieur est aujourd'hui le front
national ou gerbe avocat soir c'est un
enjeu supérieure vous avez pas vocation
à vous présenter aux élections
régionales sur cette tête de cette liste
n'a pas vocation à se présenter elle n'a
pas vocation à l'heure certains de
l'appel 10 si vous n'y arrivez pas eh
ben on présentera une liste mais je
crois que c'est ces bruits au broadway
pub mais non non c'est alors là vraiment
moi je suis je suis député j'ai déjà
beaucoup de travail à faire je ne suis
je suis contre le cumul des mandats
par contre je crois vraiment à travers
une dynamique comme ça on peut réunir
tout le monde est là on ne réunit pas
autour d'un parti ont réuni tout le
monde ensemble
en cas de risque front national est ce
qu'il faudrait pas retirer la liste de
gauche si elle arrive en 3ème et qualité
heureusement lots divers auxquels on
risque de faire face c'est à dire soit
la liste de gauche parce qu'elle est
trop loin derrière est obligée de se
retirer parce que s'il ne se retire pas
marine le pen arriverait au pouvoir donc
ça veut dire que pendant cinq ans ce
sera la droite dure qui sera au pouvoir
n'y aura aucun élu de gauche soit des
élus ne se retireront pas certains nous
ont dit on ne veut pas se retirer pour
parfaire notre hymne aux indemnités
quand même soit ils ne se retire pas et
donc on aura quelques élus de gauche
effectivement mais on aura marine le pen
emma et marine le pen au pouvoir dans la
région c'est un boulevard pour
l'élection présidentielle ce qu'ils
pensent l'un vers ce qu'il dit ça va
faire peur aux gens se trompent
il suffit de regarder ce qui se passe
dans les communes aujourd'hui qu'ils
sont administrés par le front national
au contraire ça s'implante et ça fait
tâche d'huile en fait si martine aubry
s'était d'engager tout ça ne serait pas
arrivé
elle avait la possibilité peut-être de
faire ce rassemblement mais mais pour
moi il n'ya pas d'hommes ou de femmes
providentiels dans ces histoires là il
faut vraiment réussir à créer une
dynamique et une dynamique c'est dire
voilà problème la politique du
gouvernement pose des problèmes mais on
a travaillé dans les régions ensemble il
faut qu'on continue elle sa et pour vous
françois hollande est le candidat
naturel légitime
vous parlez de la présidentielle parce
que parce que c'est un on est en train
de lui ouvrir la porte
donc il faut faire attention maintenant
la présidentielle de 2017 franchement
vous avez vu un peu les enjeux qui a à
gérer un vent donc on s'en occupera
promis mais après on voulait pas
vraiment répondre sur françois hollande
non parce que pour l'instant mon opinion
n'est absolument pas fait aujourd'hui la
présidentielle pour moi c'est loin je
sais que c'est vraiment l'élection phare
tout le monde ne pense qu'à ça
moi je ne pense pas qu'à ça je pense
qu'il ya des étapes avant très
importante à ne pas louper donc associé
duclos et l'hyper ospel si son problème
alors on avance dans la semaine il ya eu
ces déclarations ces nouvelles
déclarations d' emmanuel macron le
ministre estime qu'être élu est un
cursus d'un ancien temps un jugement qui
ne passe pas très bien auprès de
certains élus de droite comme de gauche
emmanuel macron n'en finit plus de
bousculer son camp après les 35 heures
ou le statut des fonctionnaires
celui qui est présenté comme le bon
élève du gouvernement s'est attaqué aux
élus lors d'une conférence il a annoncé
qu'il ne se
pas candidat aux législatives en 2017
car être député c'est le cursus honorum
d'un ancien temps autrement dit pas
nécessaire d'être élu pour exercer les
plus hautes fonctions
une petite phrase qui tombe à pic alors
que solférino envisageait d'investir
emmanuel macron pour les prochaines
législatives
cette nouvelle sortie du ministre de
l'économie non encartés au ps a du mal à
passer
c'est un ministre d'ouverture et le
parti socialiste ne polémique pas avec
un ministre d'ouverture
ce qu'il dit ne nous engage pas est ce
tu nous pensons langage pas on en
restera là
d'autres au contraire s'en amuse on voit
que macro n'a jamais été élu donc il ne
connais pas ni les saveurs que
représente le bonheur d'être élu par les
citoyens par ses compatriotes puisqu'il
ne veut pas il ne connaîtra jamais ce
bonheur tant pis pour lui à droite on
moque les prises de position du ministre
pour christian jacob
les sorties des manuels macron relève du
nombrilisme et la seule préoccupation
des manuels macron le voit bien depuis
plusieurs mois c'est de préparer de
préparer son atterrissage dans quelques
mois dans un grand conseil
d'administration dans une banque
d'affaires le reste il en a absolument
rien à faire mais ses déclarations agace
jusqu'au plus haut niveau de l'exécutif
en marge d'un déplacement manuel valls a
recadré son ministre qualifiant le
statut d'élu d'irremplaçable pour ce
sujet déjà bertolo mais sur ce coup
ressources aux normes selon emmanuel
macron vous êtes élu vous lui répondez
quoi je lui réponds que quand on est élu
on ne peut pas rester juste dans son
milieu à soi on ne peut pas rester juste
dans son milieu aussi sociale ou
professionnelle quand on est élu on
rencontre énormément de gens que l'on
n'aurait peut-être jamais rencontrés
dans d'autres circonstances
et ça nous ouvre un peu l'esprit et
c'est ce qui fait parfois d'ailleurs
faut faire attention parce qu'on peut
après tomber dans la démagogie quand on
est élu parce qu'on veut faire plaisir à
tout le monde mais ça nous permet de
mieux comprendre les gens qui nous
entourent et qu'on ne verrait pas
forcément si on restait toujours un peu
dans sa tour d'ivoire
moi ce que c'est ce que je lui reproche
à emmanuel macron c'est parfois de
lancer des phrases en se disant oui
intellectuellement
j'ai des choses à dire mais peut-être
sauf que il faut savoir à qui on parle
on ne parle pas des statistiques on
parle à des gens et quand on est élu ces
gens on les voit je peux me les bulles
et par martine aubry croyez pas ça mais
vous avez dernier album accrochez vous
il ne fait pas du bien au débat public
il a le droit d'avoir des positions moi
je lui reconnais de porter des débats
mais ce que ce soit sur les
fonctionnaires que ce soit sur les élus
dans ces cas là plutôt qu'ils aillent
dans la proposition et qui disent voilà
moi je verrais une orientation qui irait
vers ce sens là il dit juste des petites
phrases la petite phrase ce n'est pas
bon pour le débat pas leur cycle et jean
christophe cambadélis a dit qu' de paul
et qui ne manquait pas avec un ministre
d'ouverture est ce que vous le verriez
par exemple dans un éventuel prochain
gouvernement de droite
il ferait un bon ministre je voiture
prêtée
ça dépend calice gouvernement après il a
montré qu'il était incompatible avec
beaucoup de beaucoup de familles
politiques manifestement alors on va
changer un petit peu de sujets vous
siéger à la commission des affaires
culturelles et de l'éducation à
l'assemblée nationale et l'assemblée et
le sénat aujourd'hui on fait des
propositions cette semaine en tout cas
pour réformer l'audio visuel public
mesures chocs notamment proposé par le
sénat vous allez écouter ce reportage
l'assemblée a fait aussi des
propositions que je voudrais avoir votre
sentiment juste après reportage pauline
dame refonder le système audiovisuel
français un défi de taille pour un
secteur fragilisé par des ressources
incertaine et des charges de plus en
plus lourdes pour remettre du fioul dans
la machine les sénateurs proposent
d'augmenter la redevance de deux euros
pendant deux ans seconde étape 2018 et
une nouvelle contribution une redevance
élargi aux possesseurs de tablettes et
smartphones mais le sénat va plus loin
d'ici 2020 c'est une sorte de bbc à la
française qui pourrait faire partie du
nouveau paysage audiovisuel
baptisée france médias elle
rassemblerait l'ensemble des médias de
service public radio télévision et
numérique à l'horizon de cinq ou dix ans
le service public en france peut mourir
au profit d'un ou de plusieurs très gros
opérateurs numériques ça suppose que
nous cherchons des économies en
profondeur à travers les mutualisations
notamment l'idée c'est pas de fusionner
les rédactions mais c'est de faire en
sorte que un correspondant d'une des
stations voit ses reportages repris par
les autres dans les couloirs de france
télé on s'inquiète déjà des
répercussions sociales de cette fusion
le rtf ou était morte c'est un phénix le
rtf revient on fait du neuf avec du
vieux
quand on parle de mutualisation quand on
parle de rassembler les potentiels sans
doute un des objectifs est un objectif
social avec des réductions de coûts avec
des réductions de personnel à la paix à
venir on n'est pas dupe non plus un
dossier explosif
les sénateurs espèrent la mise en place
de cette nouvelle instance au mieux
après la prochaine élection
présidentielle
pour la ministre rappelle redoublement
n'est pas du tout sur cette position 1
euros de redevance supplémentaire pas de
pub après 20 heures que sous-entend
secondes
t aujourd'hui on en parle de plan social
à france télévisions on a un système qui
ne permet pas de financer aujourd'hui
l'audiovisuel public donc il faut
trouver des solutions
les propositions qui sont avancés par
les sénateurs je les partage pas tout
notamment sur la redevance c'est déjà on
a déjà une redevance qui augmentait ce
qu'il faut les augmenter encore plus je
ne sais pas par contre il ya des
propositions très intéressantes
notamment sur le financement de la
création sur le fait que france
télévisions puisse avoir des droits sur
sur les créations qu'elles financent
aujourd'hui elle ne peut pas y avoir
accès sur les mutualisations il faut
pouvoir par les mutualisations de
manière c'était alors d'assurer la
publicité il y a aussi des éléments très
intéressants
je crois qu'il faut pas avoir de tabou
sur ce sujet sur la publicité
aujourd'hui il y a des propositions qui
sont faites que je trouve très
intéressante qui sont par exemple
d'interdire la pub lors des pros
ramant pour les enfants voilà quelque
chose d'intéressant et donc avoir une
approche plus éthique de la pub pourrait
faire qu'on pourrait la réintroduire
après 20 heures ce qui permettrait de
donner un peu d'air pour le financement
de france télévisions tout en disant bon
on en met plus pour les programmes pour
enfants et les publicités devront
répondre à une forme de cahier des
charges c'est à dire qu'on ne pourra pas
mettre n'importe quelle publicité sur le
service public
voilà des idées qui me paraissent
intéressantes et qui répondent à la
question essentielle est-ce qu'on veut
toujours avoir un service public de
l'audiovisuel dans ce pays oui ou non si
on le veut on s'en donne les moyens
alors mercredi barbara pompili le
gouvernement présente le budget 2016 16
milliards d'euros d'économies la
poursuite des baisses de charges
engagées bercy tentent de manoeuvrer
entre relance et rigueur point noir de
ce projet de loi le déficit le détail
avec elisa bertolo mais un budget sans
surprise
voilà comment le définit le ministre des
finances la plupart des propositions
reprennent des mesures déjà engagées
ainsi la poursuite de la mise en oeuvre
du crédit d'impôt compétitivité emploi
et du pacte de responsabilité
cette année les réductions de
prélèvement pour les entreprises
atteindront 9 milliards d'euros
du côté des ménages le gouvernement
s'engage de nouveau à diminuer l'impôt
sur le revenu pour la troisième année
consécutive l'impôt sur le revenu sera
allégée pour les ménages à hauteur de
plus de 2 milliards d'euros depuis l'été
ce sont donc 5 milliards d'euros de
baisses comme annoncé et 12 millions
deux tiers des foyers fiscaux qui sont
concernés ces mesures ont pour objectif
de soutenir la reprise économique
l'année prochaine bercy table sur une
croissance de 1,5 pour cent contre 1%
actuellement comme les années
précédentes le gouvernement s'engage à
diminuer le déficit public estimé à 3 3%
du pib en 2016
bercy espère le ramener à 2
7 % en 2010 est à nouveau l'état va donc
devoir se serrer la ceinture en 2016
les administrations publiques
réaliseront 16 milliards d'économies
nous vous avions annoncé 14 5 milliards
qui étaient initialement prévus nous
avons renforcé ce programme d'économies
pour atteindre les 16 milliards
d'économies cela se traduit par des
crédits alloués aux ministères et aux
opérateurs en baisse au niveau des
ministères des économies vont être
réalisés sur plusieurs missions comme
par exemple l'aide au logement ou
l'écologie l'éducation la sécurité et la
justice reste sanctuary zay est ce que
pour vous la feuille de route est claire
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec la
ligne budgétaire fixé par le
gouvernement en est à vous vous le voter
son budget un jeu que vous mettez le
doigt exactement sur le problème ces
problèmes de la clarté
oui alors par exemple non mais sur un
sujet qui me tient particulièrement à
coeur et qu'il y ait le sujet de
l'écologie en général on a une baisse de
100 millions du budget du ministère de
l'écologie donc on est sur un signal qui
est très négatif or l'écologie c'est un
peu plus large que ça et quand on
regarde notamment tous les financements
de la transition énergétique par exemple
j'ai les financements de la transition
énergétique en gros on a une
augmentation de 1,2 milliard + 1
milliard de fonds pour les collectivités
territoriales pour les aider à investir
et notamment la moitié de ce fonds c'est
pour des investissements sur la
transition énergétique
donc voyez bien 100 millions d'un côté
1,2 milliard de l'autre sauf que on a
aucune clarté et puis alors on à
l'improvisation totale sur la question
du diesel qui quand même un petit peu
centrale on a une improvisation totale
sur l'aide publique au développement qui
fait donc alors que dans ce budget il ya
des choses positives et intéressante et
bien la communication ça n'est
absolument de cohérence aussi maman ça
manque en tout cas d'une cohérence dans
la proche aidant une cohérence de
communication donc c'est vraiment moi ce
que j'ai reprocher ce budget après il ya
du positif il ya du négatif au positif
mais moi je serais plutôt pour voter ce
budget parce que globalement
il ya des avancées il ya des baisses de
2 milliards aussi d'impôt pour des les
populations modestes et moyennes
il ya vraiment des gens intéressants
dans ce budget mais cette totale
improvisation 20 qui nous donne le
sentiment d'une totale improvisation
notamment sur les questions importantes
comme l'écologie me donne le sentiment
comme d'habitude que quand il n'ya pas
d'écologistes et bien ça n'est pas très
clair quand il ya c'est vrai que ça va
aussi
on va voir vraiment un sentiment de
clarté dans votre groupe
parce que souvent le budget c'est ce qui
déclenche ou pas mais ça va sillonner
avec ou pas la ligne rouge est donc là
on va vraiment savoir exactement où vous
positionnez serre que vous dites je suis
prêt à voter ce budget on sait qu'une
partie peut-être de troupeau tout cas
d'europe écologie les verts aujourd'hui
à l'international pour votre s'abstenir
ou voter contre
qu'est ce qui va se passer dans ce
groupe comment vous avez géré autrement
mais là dessus on a déjà eu des votes
très différents et notamment sur le
budget donc ça c'est pas nouveau c'est
déjà les difficultés sont déjà apparus
avant le budget ne fera pas éclater le
nom si le groupe réussit là à se donner
les moyens de réussir en se donnant des
méthodes de travail on pourra passer et
on a l'habitude encore une fois d'être
traversés par des divergences
d'approchés
maintenant en ce qui me concerne je
considère que quand on est dans une
majorité on vote le budget au bout d'un
moment il faut être assez clair vous
reprenez votre liberté alors parce que
jusque là c'était compliqué ben non la
majorité c'est voter les budgets et
c'est voter confiance mais on a voté les
budgets étant une question parce que
vous présenter un rapport sur l'école
inclusive dans le cadre de ce débat
budgétaire oui on voulait en parler
justement l'école d'autres adaptée aux
besoins de chaque élève en difficulté
c'est l'école inclusive qu'est ce que
c'est l'école inclusive c'est par
opposition à l'école exclusive celle qui
écrit que nous aujourd'hui on a une
école qui exclut clairement aujourd'hui
quand on est d'une population un peu
défavorisé on a moins de chances que les
autres de réussir aujourd'hui quand on
est un enfant qui a un handicap qu'il ya
un trouble on est le plus souvent
écartés de l'école pour aller dans des
dans le système médico social et c'est
là l'école inclusive c'est vraiment un
changement d'approché qui a commencé un
déjà depuis un certain temps mais
l'école doit s'adapter à ses élèves
et ce n'est plus aux élèves de s'adapter
à l'école et tous les élèves tous les
enfants de ce pays ont leur place à
l'école ça fait
partie de notre culture commune et donc
l'école doit s'y adapter
c'est un une grosse une grosse volonté
politique mon rapport vise à montrer un
peu comment ça se passe sur le terrain
les difficultés d'application
je ne vous je peux vous dire d'ores et
déjà qu'il ya un gros travail à faire
notamment sur la formation des
professeurs qui sont demandeurs tout à
l'heure on parlait du diesel vous avez
peut-être noté le et cinq mesures
annoncées par ségolène royal pour lutter
contre la pollution des écoutes et
ségolène royal et puis vous réagissez
juste après c'est beaucoup plus réactif
d'abord parce que dès que le pic de
pollution est prévue la décision est
prise et non plus comme lorsqu'on a
constaté qu'il ya vraiment la pollution
et qu'elle est là donc ça c'est très
important parce qu'on peut prévoir à
trois jours trois jours avant donc là la
survenance d'un épisode de pollution les
décisions seront prises avant tout à
l'heure sur paris il ya toujours rien
sur le diesel
comment vous expliquez ça vaut
franchement je ne m'explique que parce
que décidément quand il n'ya pas
d'écologistes dans un gouvernement on a
du mal à faire corps avec beaucoup rire
ça fait 15 ans que je les dis donc c'est
pas nouveau et ça se confirme
bon là on a entendu qu'il y allait y
avoir une loi de finances rectificative
qui allait donc prendre des mesures sur
la fiscalité des carburants et puis des
mesures sur la pollution de l'air nous
on avait déjà déposé une proposition de
loi pour justement mettre en place un
dispositif automatique quand il ya des
pics de pollution pour éviter les
atermoiements qu'on a vue sécuritaire
notamment sur la circulation alternée
mais sur des mesures à prendre pour
vraiment baissé tout de suite la
pollution faut pas oublier que ceux qui
sont punis par les pollutions
ce sont les gens qui ne peuvent plus
sortir ce sont les gens qui sont malades
sont les personnes âgées etc etc
donc on ne punit pas en donnant quelques
mesures ont au contraire on trouve des
solutions et c'est ça que vous avez fait
question du diesel parce que même
monsieur macron dit que le dl on n'y
touche pas donc il ya une question d'
économique derrière ça va beaucoup plus
loin que ça bien sûr qu'il ya une
question économique les lobbys et bien
sûr qu'il ya une question économique on
a oublié de le bien
bien sûr on a orienté toute notre
production sur le diesel toute notre
production automobile sur le diesel
aujourd'hui on revient en arrière mais
ça va prendre en revient en arrière on
va de l'avant rien on va de l'avant
retrouver pour trouver d'autres
solutions de déplacement mais ce qu'il
faut c'est effectivement aller vers des
véhicules plus propres
entre guillemets c'est jamais propre un
véhicule mais d'autres modes de
déplacement toussaint sa demande à ne
mettre en place des politiques publiques
le diesel n'a pas d'avenir dans ce pays
mais on va pas faire ça du jour au
lendemain il y a des gens aujourd'hui
qui ont besoin de leur voiture qu'on
peut pas laisser comme ça dans les bois
non c'est non c'est non pas la
conférence climat dans un instant me
repasser au jeudi avec le sénat qui se
réforme et 7d connu les absents ont
toujours tort ce 1er octobre premier
jour d'application du nouveau règlement
du sénat avec la mise en place de
pénalités financières à l'encontre des
sénateurs absolue explications et
détails quant à canet principale volonté
avec ce nouveau règlement mieux
organiser le travail des sénateurs avec
notamment un nouvel agenda plus clair
plus de chevauchement entre réunions des
commissions les séances et autres
auditions l'ambition c'est éviter cette
image celle d'un hémicycle déserté
pendant l'examen d'un projet de loi et
pour améliorer la présence dans
l'hémicycle
il est désormais possible de sanctionner
les absentéistes s'il manque trop de
questions d'actualité de réunions de
commissions ou encore de vote en séance
les sénateurs seront ainsi directement
privé d'une partie de leurs indemnités
une mesure qui laisse certains perplexes
c'est la pressent de revenir à l'école
primaire c'est cautionner finalement
l'opinion publique qui pensent que leurs
parlementaires les représente mal ce qui
n'est pas vrai parce que il y a à la
fois le travail en commission mais il ya
aussi beaucoup de missions il ya aussi
beaucoup de groupes d'étude et aussi
beaucoup d'auditions
enfin dernier volet majeur de cette
réorganisation le nouvel encadrement des
temps de parole afin d'accélérer les
échanges dans l'hémicycle une mesure
déjà mise en place depuis la rentrée
parlementaire
c'est que pour nous qui sommes dans les
métiers
que ce soit plus dynamique et plus
vivant il ya une réduction du temps de
parole sur un certain nombre de débats
et donc ça va nuire effectivement à
l'intervention pluraliste dans
l'hémicycle et ça va toucher
particulièrement les petits groupes en
vigueur demain pour accélérer la
modernisation du sénat et sans doute
aussi en améliorer l'image barbara pompe
il est avant de vous interroger je salue
l'entrée sur son plateau de jinsha c'est
notre collègue pénalités financières
entre autres
évidemment avec le travail parlementaire
beaucoup plus recadrer beaucoup plus
loin en avance vite au sénat à
l'assemblée c'est le plus difficile ça
existe déjà mais là on a un vrai travail
pédagogique à faire sur ce que font les
parlementaires aujourd'hui on croit
qu'un parlementaire c'est quelqu'un qui
est assis dans l'hémicycle et qui lève
le bras c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
que ça le travail d'un parlementaire et
je rejoins ce qui a été dit on travaille
en commission ont fait des rapports
voyez moi par exemple j'ai fait un album
j'ai fait énormément d'audition pendant
ses auditions la gt pas dans l'hémicycle
est pensé pour vous dire j'étais quand
même en train de bien travailler donc
qu'il y ait des pénalités pour ce qui
manifestement ne savent même pas à quoi
ressemble les sièges du sénat parce
qu'ils ne viennent jamais ça s'éteint
c'est un vrai sujet et il faut peut-être
le faire maintenant ça ne peut pas être
fait seul
il faut qu'il ait vraiment une pédagogie
sur le travail des parlementaires et
même une mise en valeur de ce qu'est
leur réel travail des députés et des
sénateurs il ya des propositions aussi
la venue de l'assemblée nationale et
notamment sur l'avenir des institutions
qui est co présidé par claude bartolone
et parmi les propositions la limitation
du nombre de mandats des élus à 3
consécutif c'est une bonne chose pour
vous ça oui j'ai moi j'ai toujours prôné
ce à trois mandats ça permet quand même
de prendre le temps d'avoir une
expérience et de pouvoir aussi la
transmettre est ce suffisant au bout de
trois mandats notamment un mandat de
parlementaire ses 15 ans c'est bien
quinze ans après il faut savoir aussi
passer à autre chose
par contre je parle de mandat soit
parlementaire soit exécutif
parce que quand on est conseiller
municipal d'opposition un peu isolé dans
sa commune
franchement ça n'est pas la même
situation hoarau jim est avec nous nous
allons passer à la loupe du scan alors
barbara pompili on l'a dit vous allez
vous avez quitté europe écologie pour
des raisons essentiellement politiques
liées à la stratégie d'alliance en vue
des régionales
est-ce que sur le fond des propositions
vous allez continuer à porter les
combats d'europe écologie je vais
prendre deux exemples la centrale
nucléaire de fessenheim dont la
fermeture a été reporté à 2017
est ce que ça vous agace évidemment oui
évidemment et vous allez faire savoir au
président hollande a gelé déjà fait
savoir à de nombreuses personnes et
publiquement les combats écologistes je
les partage toujours je reste
écologistes nous avons des divergences
d'appréciation sur les stratégies
politiques essentiellement et puis
quelques points mais sur fessenheim
voilà un point qui rassemble tous les
écologistes
et puis c'est aussi important dans une
dynamique de changement de notre
politique énergétique
à un moment fessenheim on a dit qu'on
allait l'arrêter que ce ne serait pas la
seule centrale que ça n'allait pas être
le seul réacteur
si on met pas en place un calendrier qui
permettent de rassurer un petit peu tout
le monde est de savoir où on va
franchement ça ne rend service à
personne
deuxième exemple la question la
proportionnelle cnct c'est une
profession une promesse de françois
hollande qui n'a toujours pas donné lieu
à une wii deuxième promesse à quoi que
ce soit est ce que vous allez pousser en
ce sens continue à pousser en ce sens
pour plus de proportionnelle
vous savez nous avons même déposé une
proposition de loi et qui a aidé n'est
pas forcément été signé par tout le
monde d'ailleurs dans notre groupe mais
nous n'avons signé et nous sommes pour
cette proportionnelle pourquoi parce que
ça peut permettre de redonner du sens à
ce qu'est le parlement
aujourd'hui le parlement c'est
l'assemblée de la nation c'est supposé
représenter tout le monde
or ça ne représente pas tous la
proportionnelle ce serait quand même le
moyen qu'il y ait plus de diversité
politique et même de diversité aussi
sociales que vous êtes le maître a mené
ce combat aux côtés des centristes
lui dénie le modem qui pensent à peu
près la même chose que vous ah oui mais
vous savez moi je ne suis pas cloisonner
je ne dis pas moi parce que monsieur
attey l'étiquette je n'écoute pas ce
qu'il dit moi j'écoute ce que disent les
gens quand il ya des choses qui sont
intéressantes et bien je travaille avec
tous lancés sur ce sujet on appelle à
l'ouverture mais on a déjà
mais la proportion ça veut dire aussi
plus d'élus le risque de plus d'élus
front national à l'assemblée aussi que
vous combattez oui d'ailleurs mais je
combats le front national je combats ses
idées mais à partir du moment où il ya
des gens qui votent pour lui il n'y a
pas de raison qu'ils ne soient pas
représentés je les ai toujours dit on ne
luttera pas contre le front national par
des bidouillages institutionnels non il
faut se battre sur les idées il faut se
battre pour redonner des perspectives
aux gens et quand on leur donnera des
perspectives est belle votre au moins
pour le front national on repart le
nord-pas-de-calais picardie sur votre
blog vous critiquer le système des
appareils partisans de lens reçoit jeu
citant des politiciens professionnels
suscite encore vous avez tout de même
construit votre propre carrière autour
du parti écologiste
il ya une réaction cette semaine après
votre départ c'est celle de la députée
écologiste daniel roy lui qui à 10,2 à
votre sujet au sujet de françois de rugy
ce sont des enfants gâtés de la
politique qui ont commencé comme
collaborateur parlementaire et qui n'ont
jamais connu la réalité sociale ça non
mais d'une manière générale les injures
publiques parce que c'est le cas sont en
disent beaucoup plus sur les personnes
qui les profèrent que sur les personnes
qui les subissent on attend plus d'une
parlementaire que d'insulter ses
collègues
on attend d'elle qu'elle fasse de
l'argumentation politique qu'on parle de
fonds aujourd'hui malheureusement on ne
veut pas avoir ce débat de fond et c'est
plutôt les raisons pour lesquelles on ne
veut pas voir ce débat de fond qu'il
faudrait interroger
donc vous vous maintenez de le fait de
d'être une élue est d'être au contact de
proximité avec la société civile et vous
savez je vous invite à venir me suivre
pendant une semaine et vous verrez et
vous verrez ce que c'est que le travail
d'un élu et d'un élu qui est sur le
terrain est pour moi un élu qui n'est
pas sûr de terrain c'est un élu qui ne
peut pas faire correctement son travail
est une élue a fortiori c'est pareil de
la question une activité dont on a
évidemment beaucoup parlé cette semaine
c'est nadine morano qui part de la
france comme d'un pays de race bleue
c'est quoi pour vous c'est un dérapage
ou c'est un appel du pied aux électeurs
du front national
les deux mais c'est surtout que ça
montre que les digues sont de plus en
plus qu'on avait et on a toujours un
socle de valeurs dans notre pays et que
ces valeurs parce que les gens encore
une fois non pas de perspective parce
que les gens sont angoissés par l'avenir
ces valeurs sont foulées aux pieds parce
que mais il y a un discours qui se
développe pour dire pour répondre à vos
angoisses
il faut se replier sur soi il faut
rejeter l'autre et on trouvera des
solutions comme ça non évidemment ne
trouvera pas des solutions comme ça le
racisme c'est duras parce que c'est du
racisme le racisme doit être condamnée
absolument il ne faut pas qu'on revienne
en arrière sur toutes les avancées
humaniste qu'on a eu depuis cent il ya
un débat qui rejoint cette semaine c'est
la suppression du mot race dans la
législation c'était encore une fois une
promesse de françois hollande
vous êtes favorable est-ce que ça suffit
de supprimer le mot pour supprimer le
sénat
on attend toujours c'est au sénat la
balle est dans le camp du sénat la balle
est donc samedi soir justement que ça
s'accélère dans louis parce que parce
que ça permettrait clarifier les choses
les races ça n'a aucun sens ça n'existe
pas pour les humains donc au bout d'un
moment voulaient retirer la législation
va pas raconter une question qu'on a
survolé un petit peu mais depuis
tellement oui dit il faut des
écologistes gouvernement sauriez prête à
rejoindre gouvernement mais alors ça
c'est pareil
voilà on me dit vous avez quittez europe
ecologie les verts pour aller au
gouvernement il ya un mois on me disait
vous restez europe écologie et verts
parce que vous voulez aller au
gouvernement
bref à chaque fois qu'on prend une
décision de fond politique des personnes
pour des raisons qui leur appartiennent
le noie en disant c'est pour des
ambitions personnelles ça fait 15 ans
que je fais de la politique ça fait 15
ans que je dis que les écologistes
doivent passer des compromis pourrait
dans les exécutifs quels qu'ils soient
donc évidemment aussi au gouvernement
moi quand cécile duflot y passe quelques
enfants sont partis j'étais dévastée or
il ne s'agissait pas de moi il
s'agissait de deux autres personnes donc
oui il faut qu'il y ait des écologistes
au mouvement
moi je rentrerai au gouvernement si on
me donne les moyens d'agir sur des
sujets alexis lui et quartz voilà mais
encore une fois si c'est pas moi 6 et
d'autres personnes je serais heureuse
vraiment cdn
merci merci à vous alors barbara propres
je vous propose de terminer avec eux des
images d'un film choc sur
l'environnement sur la planète
yeomans c'est le titre du film réalisé
par yann arthus bertrand diffusé cette
semaine sur france 2 le photographe a
fait le tour du monde pour nous montrer
une autre planète et surtout une autre
humanité extrait depuis près de 40 ans
je photographie notre planète pour
essayer de comprendre la terre sur
laquelle je vis alors que l'humanité
progresse j'ai le sentiment qu'on vit
toujours dans un monde à deux vitesses
plongez dans les inégalités déchiré par
les guerres on n'arrive toujours pas à
vivre ensemble aujourd'hui naïvement
comme un enfant pourrait le faire j'ai
envie de poser une question
pourquoi pourquoi de génération en
génération reproduite ont les mêmes
erreurs
ce n'est pas dans les chiffres les
statistiques le chercher une réponse est
dans l'homme pour ce film
une seule question parce qu'il nous
reste peu de temps françois hollande
semble tenir un discours de plus en plus
alarmistes et sea mist sur le succès de
la coop 21 c'est un problème c'est un
problème et je crois que le film
justement montre sage ait pas encore eu
l'occasion de le voir mais j'en ai
beaucoup entendu parler il faut une
volonté politique forte de tout le monde
pour pouvoir avancer
alors on voit que ça commence à bouger
on voit que la conscience et mer y
compris dans des pays qui au départ
n'était pas facile sur ces questions la
chine l'inde bouge donc qu'il a voulu
montrer avec ce club voilà ça bouge donc
maintenant il faut que ce soit relayée
par les politiques qui sont souvent en
retard d'ailleurs sur les populations
est bien là que les politiques montrent
qu'ils sont capables de s'engager et de
s'engager vraiment et il faut continuer
à pousser dans ce sens il cessera le mot
de la fin merci barbara pompili
ressentons personnes prochaine bonne
semaine à tous
oh